foreign
it is used in diverse ways in the form
of salads
juices sauces ingredient for various
urinary preparations
Etc
interestingly China ranks number one
and the largest producer of tomatoes
and the next point is a tomato plant
information
botanically called
percicum
tomato plants are actually wines if we
will adequate support
they can grow up to six feet to tall
in traditional farming in greenhouses
they can live up to three years
The Vines are covered with short hairs
all over and the flowers are yellow in
color
and the next point is ideal conditions
for tomato cultivation
it can't tolerate height right
intensity as well as as well since it
affects the fruit pigmentation
our next point is the climate for a
tomato farming being one seasoned crop
tomato crop requires an ideal
temperature of 21 to 30 23 degrees C
tomatoes are highly sensitive to
climatic changes for ideal growth and
yield tomatoes need a diverse effect of
climatic conditions at very every stage
of
growth such as seed germination
flowering fruiting Etc tomato farming
needs a warm and food climate with
medium sunlight both heavy rainfall and
a prolonged with a dry spells affect the
growth of tomato plants
our next wine diesel soil for tomato
cultivation tomato needs a virus set of
climate for its growth
diverse effect of climate for its growth
it can grow on all types of soils from
light sandy soil to heavy creamy soil
a well-drained soil with a depth of 15
to 20 cm is ideal for yielding a healthy
crop
pH for tomato farming soil PH falling in
the range of food
6.2 6.0 to 0.0 is preferred
along with adequate nutrient Supply can
help to Tomato crops grow better in
acidic soil
and the next point is water requirement
in tomato Plantation
converters are sensitive to both excess
water as well as very little water image
is challenging tomato cultivation is
maintained and even moisture Supply
during summer it is necessary to
irrigate the crop once a week while
irrigating it once in every two weeks is
the sufficient
care should be taken to prevent any
drought period after a heavy
watering goes drought followed by an
abruptive
watering during the fruiting
phase would cause cracking in tomatoes
our next point is a crop rotation with
the Tomato crop
tomato belongs to solanasia family it
can't be rotated with other crops
belonging to the same family like potato
tobacco bell pepper
Etc it must be rotated with crops
that fulfill the nitrogen content of the
soil leguminous crops are the most
recommended for this purpose
tomato crops are hence rotated with a
leguminous crops like beans pulses Etc
next point is the land preparation for
tomato cultivation
the field for growing tomatoes must be
thoroughly indicated and decimated and
fragmented thorough repeated flowing it
means about
five programs five plugins before
cultivation the step after plowing is
leaving leveling the land is level in
the evenings and beds are prepared for
planting the tomato seeds the land must
be sterilized after plowing
so as to destroy the disease causing
fascism on the microbes
they are commonly sterilized by
solarizations
[Music]
and next point is the season for tomato
Plantation
since the tomatoes are dead neutral they
can be grown during any season in the
southern part Circle
in southern past
tomatoes are transplanted in three
Cycles December to January
the transplantation schedule is below
the crop next point is Krampus
February months Jade season it
transplanted during September and
October months in the Southern Plains
only if adequate irrigation facilities
are available
similarly in the northern
plants in the Northern Plains a Ravi
crop may not be taken since they may get
affected
during winter
seeds these seeds the seeds are first
raised in the nurseries and then
transplanted
after a period of 30 to 40 days 45 days
hybrid and exodico varieties are sown in
small plastic cups while other varieties
that are not too closely to produce are
soon in a nursery beds especially for
the purpose
next point is transplantation
transplantation is done in Shallow
furrows or flat beds as per the
irrigation availability during the
monsoon and in case of heavy soils
seedlings are planted in brine in dry it
in bridges
so that the water doesn't get robbed in
case of hybrids and in the determinative
varieties seedlings must be stacked
using bamboo sticks if planted in
furrows then they are planted at a
spacing of a 30 cm from each other
for spring summer crop the spacing
maintained is 75 to 45 cm and 75 to 60
cm for ottoman winter crop
and the next point is harvesting from
tomato Plantation Tomatoes can be
harvested within two to three months of
Plantation depending on the market you
demand
harvesting of tomato is done on a yearly
basis the average tomato crop yield for
actually India is about 10 tons although
the yield varies from 15 to 20 tons per
acre in case of irrigated crops
this is the information regarding the
Tomato Farm which is having very good
demand in the world
for commercial choices
and
vegetable work in the vegetable market
also this is the main source of
cooking pot tomato he is having very
much
so it is also a profitable problem but
only one thing is marketing areas also
Farmers you should find out
according to the marketing areas they
should Supply in time frequently
then only it will be successful only
lots of tomatoes are coming unders
there's no Market means they will lost
so much so periodical supply has to be
there to the market units so marketing
strategies are most important and where
to supply when to supply and how we can
collect their money all these things
also we should think common then only it
will be a successful successful business
because production will be there
we should catch the demand also in the
same way that is also most important so
Communications are most important in
this manner to Farmer to Farmer and
farmer to dealer and supplier and
distributor and all these so if you
maintain all these things you will be
successful in this awareness wishing you
all the way all the rest